donc il suffit de terrain lyonnais tiéné
d'elliot comme ça pour cette veine à
dessein patrick baudry à l'honneur
aujourd'hui de leur compagne c'est tout
ce passe en libye est ma passion prendra
place au cours de l'été 1982 la bord
d'un vaisseau soyouz c'est avec
alexandre il 25 ans à paris aussi on a
commémoré le 200e anniversaire de la
bataille de yorktown cela s'est passé
devant la statue du maréchal de
rochambeau première phase on peut plus
on peut plus qu'emballé c'est votre
conseil des ministres
c'est du brainstorming pour utiliser mes
yeux il ya des idées concernant ses
parts dernier par exemple et qui sont
dessinés par novo
il ya une idée qui vient d'un d'un parmi
nous et qui est reprise améliorée par un
autre aussi
il ya un brassage comme elle vient
syndic de dimanche ce avec une
couverture comme sa couverture on va
vendre le guéridon suivre aujourd'hui on
arrive à trouver quelque chose
si on arrive à faire rire ici à cette
table on se dit qu'on arrive à bien
faire rire y'a pas de raison que les
garçons du coût de couverture positive
dès 5h30 et chez vous quoi merde tous
les cas qui va arriver alors et vous
êtes dans la majorité présidentielle ça
vous embête pas de taper sur le
gouvernement que vous ému par ailleurs
on n'a pas vu beaucoup de changements là
en ce qui concerne la défense d'un final
les dieu ni maître
[Musique]